now to our exclusive interview with
Salvatore Sam and nello the grand father
accused of negligent homicide and the
death of his granddaughter Chloe Wiegand
the 18-month old fell 150 feet from a
Royal Caribbean cruise ship docked in
Puerto Rico and nella was holding the
girl up against what he thought was a
bank of closed windows when she slipped
from his grasp lead national
correspondent David beg no sat down with
an L o in his first interview since the
incident David how is he handling this
Anthony he seemed emotionally numb when
we met him yesterday he told us the
reason he wanted to do this interview
was to try and plead with Royal
Caribbean cruise line to put signs up
when and where they actually have
windows open on the ship we wanted to do
the interview
to better understand exactly what
happened this grandfather is facing
three years in prison because
prosecutors believe his actions on the
ship were reckless the process by which
he slipped how did that happen oh I know
I was trying to reach the glass and I
know that we leaned over they try to
have her reach the glass and that point
she's left
but at that moment did you realize there
was no glass I didn't realize there
wasn't any glass till the absolutely
dude was too late I mean even when she
first fell I thought she fell in front
of me
I thought she fell in front of me what
was your reaction when you found out
that you were the subject of this
criminal investigation Chloe being gone
is the worst thing ever so I'm like
whatever you know
I don't know what to help me understand
what you mean there's nothing worse that
they can do to me and what's already
happened we are gonna have more of our
exclusive interview with Salvatore
Salmonella in our next half hour he's
gonna talk about the health condition he
says he has that may have played a role
in the tragedy plus we have new details
about that surveillance video which
shows the final moments leading up to
what happened well so difficult the
details and none of it changes the fact
that I feel like three years is a lot to
put on top of somebody who's already
suffering yeah David thank you very much